most of these people in the room are
victims of election violence and police
brutality
they live in a rough neighborhood
they show us names of young people
who've been killed by gangs police or
election clashes
two sons were killed during a disputed
election in 2017. she says her boys were
caught up in protests they were shot
when protesters clashed with police
elections are peaceful we want a
peaceful election the government should
provide enough security we don't want
police to come and use extreme force
their work is to protect
in the last election our young men were
provoked by them
kenyans are going to another general
election in august voters are electing a
president and other electoral seats
some people are worried there could be
violence should the outcome of the poll
be contested
this is one of the most politically
tense neighborhoods
in the city during campaigns some
politicians use guns to scare voters
many here say they have been affected by
election violence they tell us they
don't want any trouble
young artists are trying to make a
difference here they're painting a story
of the complicated relationship between
residents and police
we are worried
if there is any way to prepare the
community we will do it we are telling
young people we must not bleed for the
politicians to lead
the government has a body that is
responsible for ensuring people coexist
in harmony
officials have been traveling across the
country telling voters to keep the peace
we need to talk to the kenyan people
themselves and empower them to first of
all
reject political manipulation
and also incitement to
violence
and most importantly not to politicize
their ethnic identities
as the poll draws near
the women in this area say they will do
what they can to keep their part of the
city safe catherine soy al jazeera
nairobi